EASY NIGHT FOR THEM.
DEEP.
BOBBLING PUCK,
SAVE EARLY ON PAQUETTE.
HERE'S SAM CARRICK, HE'S  THE P
PASS.
PULLS
THE ZONE.
BACK TO COMTOIS. CAN'T CLEAR.
SHATTENKIR FOWLER FROM SHATTENK.
GETS IT BACK.
FOWLER SENDS IT ACROSS.
THE PUCK IN.
EVANS CHIPS AND CHASES.
REM PITLICK, EVANS AWAY FROM
PITLICK GOES AND GETS IT. DEFENT
SIDE OF THE NET, PUTS IT AROUND.
TRIES TO GET U
FOWLER UNDER PRESSURE.
SUZUKI FOR TOFFOLI.
PLAYED ON THE INSIDE PASS AND
OFTEN PUTS IT OUT IN THE Y TERR
WITH IT.
TROY
TERRY.
SCORES!UYS ROOM UP INR, DRIVES .
HE DID IT AGAIN, PITLICK TO
EVANS, BACK TO TFORECHECK.
AY
DOWN THERE.
>> Bryan: ZEGRAS AGAIN OVER THE.
SU GAME
SHORTHANDED.
WIDEMAN HOPS IT  HOCKEY GIEM
GAME ANDERSON, CHIPS AND SPEEDS
IN.
HE HAD TO GO THE WHOLE LENGTH OF
THE ICE TO CATCH UP TO IT.
>> Bryan: BUT HIS IN,
LEFT TO RIGHT, OPENS THE BIG
GOALTENDER UP, BUT AS BIG AS EV
OF THAT SHOT COMING IN.OR KULAK
JUST MISSED HIM.
PETRY PASS B